astronaut shannon lucid back on earth
after a record six months in space
was welcomed home tuesday with a phone
call from president clinton
said the president quote this is just
the beginning
one day we'll be able to send an
american into space indefinitely and i
hope it's a woman
but there were no victims there were no
victims only one i feel
sorry for is is that uh lewinsky i feel
a little cyborg don't y'all feel a
little sorry for her though
god damn y'all come on man have a heart
that's a hard thing to be famous for man
nobody wanna be the most famous
[ __ ] of all times
i feel bad for her not even the women
feel sorry for a little bit ladies
now that's jealousy
that's what that is i mean come on yo
that's one dick
that girl sucks it's gonna haunt her for
the rest of her life
long after she spent that money up
that's still gonna haunt her
and i know there's a lot of women in
here with at least one dick they regret
and i bet you wasn't a president's dick
i bet she worked at kenny's shoes a safe
way or something like that see we got to
stop
judging people that girl was young and
she made a mistake that
young girls make she wanted to [ __ ] a
powerful man
period that's as far as she thought it
through she wasn't thinking about how
powerful the president was
she had no wisdom oh the woman would
have helped everybody older woman
would have been in there you know you
should lower taxes
all the one want to suck us into utopia
the last thing i'm gonna say about it is
this that he is a famous man
i have dreamt of being famous but i
never dreamt of being
that famous i never understood how
famous a president was but imagine
if somebody could suck your dick and
then they're famous you understand what
i'm saying
that's crazy
that's crazy i mean no guy ever thought
of that
there's nobody with a pickup line that
good and [ __ ] they suck my dick there's
a future in it
what oh that's it now get out there and
be somebody
you're a qualified author now go write a
book
at the white house this week president
clinton officially came out against
same-sex marriages what's more the
president said he is not too crazy about
opposite sex marriages either
people say clinton has no taste in women
no he just has no opportunities
he's so in the spotlight and people
begrudge him that they begrudge him
the 10 shitty instances of prison sex
that he did get
and that's what it is it's prison sex he
was up against the wall of the
windowless hallway and the door is a
little open and she's blowing him and
he's looking
this is what the president should have
to go through
nine out of the ten times he didn't even
come that's not
discipline could you
do it oh no that's good i'm fine nope
that's fine
okay that's good no no that's good for
me i don't need to go
and the one time he does she saves it
and hangs him with it i mean come on
some of it is bad luck and anybody else
in his position would be getting such a
better type of tail
but he doesn't complain he's so
scrutinized he has to take what he can
get and he's sacrificing for you
he's making the sacrifice of not being
too particular because let's face it
he's not too particular he's not
a precise fisherman with women he's
he's got a net this guy he's whatever he
gets in that net you know monica
lewinsky
paula jones kathleen willi
an old boot you know plankton
yes the president [ __ ] plankton because
he's busy
every story you hear about it points to
the fact that he's busy paula jones
and talk about a sacrifice this
this chick could make a strap-on go limp
but you know
every story is like her story he brought
me up to the room there was a
few minutes of small talk he whips it
out busy
busy guy he's saying you want to dine at
the governor's ball
fine if you don't i got to go end
welfare as we know it i'm a very busy
guy
he is so on the case when i heard that
thing about him
uh on the phone to congressman at 2 30
in the morning
while monica's blowing him and he's
eating pizza i was
i was like thank you mr president
[Music]
tomorrow j simpson news
on friday the juice officially endorsed
bill clinton for president
adding adding quote i'd like to help him
any way i can
to which the president replied well
there is one thing
bill clinton what the [ __ ] is he
bill clinton just wild ain't it he is
buck wild man he said bill clinton is
like a pimping [ __ ]
he's a pimp bill is the closest thing to
a black president we gonna get
am i right smoking weed [ __ ] [ __ ]
bill clinton is a [ __ ] that
motherfucker's a [ __ ]
he doing some [ __ ] [ __ ] in the office
smoking weed [ __ ] hoes that's some
[ __ ] i can hang with that [ __ ]
that's the type of [ __ ] we can
hang out with and [ __ ]
and bill is a little he get a little mad
too when they start asking him too many
questions he get a little gangster [ __ ]
on him
he'd be like he'd be like hey i want the
american public
to look me in my eye now i'm sick of
this [ __ ] you [ __ ] are
trying to put on me [ __ ]
quit [ __ ] with me get off my dick
about this [ __ ] so what i got my dick
suck [ __ ] you [ __ ] with billy
c clinton up in this [ __ ] [ __ ]
bc in the house all the way from
arkansas baby arkansas
orkin says do you want to ride or die
ride or die da da
ass [ __ ] get off my dick get off
of this dick [ __ ] [ __ ]
so what she sucked at hand so what she's
sucking she didn't inhale
billy c clinton up in this [ __ ]
boy you better recognize fool
hell me and vernon hit the [ __ ] hell it
ain't no fun
if the homies can't have none
[Applause]
and of course it was very inspiring to
see president clinton up here on
crutches making a speech i mean
i thought that was just amazing you know
uh i mean it's been difficult for the
president you know he can't jog
now and he needs help getting around and
he's still
you know he still uh occasionally
suffers great pain you know
on the upside you got your medical
marijuana so that's uh
you must inhale sir it's the only way
you're gonna get better
[Applause]
it's
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm standing on the side of the road in
boston and uh
a buddy of mine wanted to go down and
see it he's like oh the president's
coming down let's go look at the [ __ ]
motorcade me and this other [ __ ]
friend of mine it was a total pothead
and we could give a [ __ ] we were
bleary-eyed we went down there
and uh clinton came down the street
he just wanted to see the motorcade and
right as he was coming to drive by us
the motor came dipped down this [ __ ]
alley
and then we're looking at our buddy
going yeah that was great dude they they
[ __ ] made a left turn and now we
didn't see it and they go no no no he's
going there to make a speech he'll
probably be in there for like an hour
i'm gonna go get a slice of pizza you
guys want anything we're like nah we're
good we're good
so the dude who wants to see the
motorcade goes off to go see if
get a [ __ ] slice of pizza me and the
pothead are [ __ ] standing there not
giving a [ __ ]
all of a sudden the crowd starts going
nuts right
going [ __ ] crazy and these secret
service guys we're behind this police
scare barricades telling everybody put
their hands up keep your hands up both
hands up we can see it
keep your hands up they're like freaking
out and all of a sudden here comes old
slick willy walking up the [ __ ]
street high-fiving people while the the
well his limo is driving slowly along
next to him with the [ __ ] door open
and walking right behind him was [ __ ]
ted kennedy
so uh i high-fived bill clinton when he
was president
before monica lewinsky this is his first
term right
soft hands soft
like [ __ ] i don't know what
creepy soft [ __ ] hands little hands
little
soft [ __ ] baby gross hands but he
didn't have long piano flame
playing fingers it was not a good
experience
i was getting who i didn't want to be
there right and then ted kennedy cam
went to high five him and the sheer
size the sheer mass of the guy's head
i literally went whoa you couldn't
[ __ ] believe the fact that get
that guy his head was so big he never
should have had a full head of hair
just out of this the sheer like surface
area of it
that just even if he had a full head of
hair it's not gonna be a full head with
that [ __ ] head
i'll tell you right now thank god that
guy didn't go bald man jesus christ that
would have been
that would have been something to look
at um
so i shook his [ __ ] hand and jesus
christ he just looked like
you know i know he was sober at that
point but that guy
that guy lived a [ __ ] he yeah he
lived a rough one you know
[ __ ] lost three of his brothers the
thing that happened to his sister
the whole [ __ ] crazy and he goes in the
lake he kills somebody
oh my god can you imagine his [ __ ]
wife sleeping next to him how much does
that guy talk in his sleep
oh you all had nothing to do with it huh
give me another drink
jack it down get down um that's brutal
anyways so then bill clinton jumps in
his [ __ ] car
ted kennedy jumps in with them they just
[ __ ] take off
and everybody's like oh my god i get a
little bit oh my god and everybody just
sort of walks away
and then like all of that took maybe
like 17 seconds
and then everybody was gone and the
whole [ __ ] thing was over it was like
it never happened
and then we turn around and here comes
my buddy coming up the street
biting into a slice of pizza and never
forget he bites in
and then he like stopped mid bite and he
looks around and he goes
ah [ __ ] he's like did i miss it
he goes did i miss it and i go
yeah and i go uh
i shook his hand
he goes what go he came walking up the
street i
i shook his head and my buddy goes no
you didn't
and then he looks over i look over and
there's my pothead friend
who's like galloping in a circle
and he's just jumping up and down as
he's galloping and he's going
i shook it twice i shook it twice
ah if you could have seen the look on
that dude's face he was so [ __ ]
disappointed we didn't even tell him
about ted kennedy
um anyways so there's that story
there's that story for you